speaking of running for office there's a
game on the web right now to figure out
your personal presidential campaign
slogan I love it it's your name the year
you want to run for president and the
last thing you texted so I feel like it
works mine and I figured this out before
the show and it's awesome - Clarkson
20:28 oh shoot you actually just
reminded me that Cassie texted me and I
never got back to her I'm such an ass
please tell her I'm so sorry I just
remembered grimace face I was like
before hand I was like I cannot believe
this is my last actually I just I texted
cab because I was actually sending him
the first two episodes that's you know
yeah he gets extra first so I just went
just for you baby like Dawson
20:28 just for you baby
[Applause]
I was living at the Met Ball and Rihanna
was performing and then like the
surprise guest was Kanye West yeah and
he came out and everyone got super
excited to see him and the first thing
he walks up to the mic with all this
like rounding applause and the first
thing he says is you're welcome
and I was like he's talking about
running for office and I think that
should be his campaign
you're welcome to West for president
actually you're welcome I actually save
it a lot myself so I can't make your
welcome I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this